und wir bleiben beim tragischen unglück
beim thema surfen wenn kelly war gerade
einmal 26 jahre alt doch jetzt ist er
tot
er hat auch gesagt an der küste in
kalifornien und jetzt ist er tot weil
ein hai an ihn attackiert hatte
normalerweise genießt die 68 jährige
terry tucker ihre aussicht dass mehr
direkt vor der tür und oft schwimmen
hier delfine
doch an diesem samstag war alles anders
direkt vom fenster aus sah sie wie der
26 jährige surfer ben kelly von einem
hai angegriffen wurde
da waren noch zwei surfer dabei und dann
die person die das opfer war
ich hatte erst gar nicht realisiert dass
es ein hai war ich sah nur eine
rückenflosse dem kampf und plötzlich war
alles ruhig
es schien unter wasser weiter zu gehen
unglücklicherweise wurde ich dann vom
fenster weg gerufen
doch als ich zurückkam war das
rettungsteam schon da am strand und ich
konnte sehen wie sie versucht haben ihn
zu retten
für die 68 jährige ein schockierendes
erlebnis besonders weil sie erst nicht
realisierte was sie gesehen hatte es sah
zunächst irgendwie abwehrende bewegungen
aus wie ich sagte aber es war mir nicht
klar dass ein hai angegriffen hat es
erschien als wirbelten seine arme herum
aber dann verschwanden sie unter wasser
es war ein todeskampf den der surfer mit
seinem leben bezahlen musste und das in
einer gegend wo er sonst eher selten
anzutreffen sind
ich denke ein todesfall in dieser gegend
gab es nicht mehr seit 1926 also eine
ganze weile her
die meisten haiangriffe gibt es in
südkalifornien bei san diego
vier oder fünf 100 meilen weiter südlich
von hier dass hier zu haben war eine
überraschung aber dass drohnen video von
einigen tagen zuvor das zeigt dass hier
viele haie jetzt unterwegs sind und es
sagte eigentlich dass man beim sport
aufpassen sollte der strand wurde nach
der hai-attacke für zunächst fünf tage
für die wassersportler
wert und terry tucker wird auch noch
zeit brauchen um das schreckliche zu
verarbeiten
ja genau über diese surf gegend wo ben
kelly ums leben gekommen ist möchte ich
jetzt mit bild reporter jens eder
sprechen er ist selbst surfer hallo
hallo ich grüße sie jetzt vielleicht
kannst uns was sagen zu der surfing was
ist das besondere an dieser gegend also
man kann die beste von amerika also
kalifornien in lokalen zog er
unterscheiden sind zwei verschiedene
kulturen und auch zwei verschiedene
gegnern wo sich die bedingungen extrem
unterscheiden man hat im norden eher
härtere bedingungen raue gewässer herbe
strömungen okay das wetter und höhere
wellen also die surfspots und hält sich
und auch gefährlich und was man auch hat
ist viel mehr
marien wildlife also sprich wale und
raubfische
im vergleich dazu ist südkalifornien
bisschen software wo ich mich befinde
wir haben im leben wirklich mal wärmeres
wetter wärmere gewässer nicht so hohen
wellengang und beben ja alles ein
bisschen sorgt für die gegend auch noch
steht die meisten gleich jetzt nicht
ausgehen
ist ja auch berühmt für big wave surfer
in der nähe von santa cruz befindet sich
auch mavericks und santa cruz selber ist
er in der sogenannten monterey bay und
monterey base eigentlich weltweit ein
sehr bekanntes wort für optische und das
hat mich etwas überrascht dass die dame
sagte das eigentlich denn je wo er für
angriffe bekannt ist das stimmt aber
gegen dort um santa cruz vor allen
dingen ab monterey bay die nennt man red
triangle und das ist eben ein haifisch
gebiet mit sehr hoher reputation
insbesondere um san francisco
wenn ihr der vater long island obwohl
ich auch sagen ja
die surfer in nord-kalifornien die
werden es sind harte kerle
wir werden also von den sich kalifornien
sehr respektierter so mal so
zu erwähnen wie ist denn jetzt die
stimmung und helfern macht man sich dort
sorgen also die stadtgemeinde ist eine
eingeschworene community die leute sind
oder die server sind betroffen und
surfern spricht also roses beileid zu
spüren und nur die leute sind nicht
überrascht damals man so man ist nicht
schockiert weil wie gesagt wir gegen das
dafür bekannt dass man dort eine hohe
population an heike stadt und
insbesondere jetzt lernt der korona zeit
scheint es auch dadurch dass keine
aktivität an den stränden gab sich so
entwickelt zu haben dass die europäische
dann näher an den küsten gekommen sind
kann auch verschiedene gründe gehabt
haben vielleicht auch weil sich deren
beute dort mehr verteilt oder verstreut
hat aber diese population und dichte die
man da jetzt gesehen hat holding mit dem
drohen video auch wo der brawn pilot
1340 weiße hai gesehen hat das habe ich
auch noch nie gehört also man macht sich
schon ein bisschen sorgen aber ich sag
mal so lange jetzt nicht in zwei drei
fisch angriff passiert in den nächsten
sechs bis zwölf monaten am würde man
eher sagen das feld ein paar normal weil
häufig passieren halt eben und ja geht
es denn überhaupt schon maßnahmen kann
man sich überhaupt vor einem angriff
schützen
es gibt schutzmaßnahmen wie zum beispiel
elektronisches also elektro leyen wies
die leine die das surfboard am körper
hält die wird meistens am fuß befestigt
dann gibt es spezielle surfern schüler
mit ihren muss dann die haie abschrecken
sollen die den haien zeigen sollen dass
man kein gutes essen ist also vielleicht
giftig ist und dann gibt es natürlich
auch eine art säure schutz die man über
das eure die man benutzen kann die
effektivität dieser maßnahme ist sehr
fragwürdig weil wenn man von einem hai
angegriffen wird und das merkt es meist
schon zu spät sei denn der hai machten
fehler und bald vorbei
eigentlich noch eine chance irgendwie
schnell wegzukommen gleich die nächste
welle zu nehmen das heißt ja auch man
soll sich nicht in solchen panik
verfallen immer leichter gesagt als
getan weil schnelle vibrationen regen
die tiere unheimlich an zum angriff in
der szene würde ich jetzt sagen es ist
nicht verbreitet regen in süd
kalifornien da sieht man jemand mit
schutzmaßnahmen im norden kann ich jetzt
nicht so beurteilen aber man muss auch
ein bisschen so die surf kultur kennen
dürften deshalb eben das spiel zwischen
mensch und natur und naturgewalt und
gefahr ist teil des spiels
und ich würde die szene auch als sehr
maskulin und ideologisch betrachten wenn
man da halt eben jetzt sage ich mal mit
schutzmaßnahmen ins wasser geht
ich sag jetzt mal prima nach
schutzwesten oder so dann würde man
eigentlich nur sport unruhen ernten also
bei dem soffin ist das eigentlich so
weit ich weiß überhaupt nicht erwartet
und man muss auch soweit ich das ist
jetzt hier mit mit dem band kelly
aber ja auch voll mutter war ich glaube
das auch nicht dass da irgendwie mit
elektro liner im wasser war aber wie
gesagt selbst wenn man das hat die
effektivität ist fraglich
für deine schilderung danke